hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
fully automated rna library preparation
for sequencing respiratory viruses
i am marie stone of lab labruts and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by beckmann coulter life sciences to
learn more visit beckman.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
dr tomas zamaschtel head of the genomics
core unit at the berlin institute of
health at cherokee
and randy pairs senior application
scientist and a member of the automated
genomics business unit with beckmann
coulter life sciences tomas and randy
you may now begin your presentations
good day everybody
it is my pleasure to have this
opportunity to present jointly with a
colleague from beckmann culture randy
paris an automated workflow for
sequencing respiratory rna viruses
even though the focus of this
presentation is on sequencing the genome
of sask of two respiratory virus
our workflow is obviously capable of
resolving whole genome sequences of full
spectrum of
rna viruses
before i begin uh i'd like to tell you a
few words on the institution that i'm
affiliated with
berlin institute of health or in short
bih is a part of the charity university
hospital berlin
shaitaa is one of the largest university
hospitals in europe
it spans over four campuses it
accommodates more than 100 departments
and institutes
it has more than 13 000 staff
employees
its annual turnover exceeds 1.3 billion
euros
the berlin institute of health
constitutes next to the university
hospital and the faculty the third
pillar of the bih
the berlin institute of health executes
a range of research programs
implementing translational activities in
the setting of the chaite university
hospital
bih clearly benefits from a strong
partnership with a top-ranked
institution in biomedical research max
debrook center
in that respect the bih genomics unit
that i'm representing today
profits from both environments
the focus of the bih genomics unit is on
providing genomic tools and implementing
them
as a part of clinical workflow to enable
patient care
the unit consists of two technology
platforms the first one centering on
single cell technologies and the other
one utilizing standard bulk ngs
approaches
the fact that my unit members include
both molecular biologists and
bioinformaticians
allows us to implement workflows
starting from clinical sample and ending
on clinical grade reporting
why would we want to sequence viral
genomes
one of the things that we learned from
the current pandemic situation
is that whole genome sequencing of viral
genomes may help us to better identify
outbreaks and track transmissions
the latter is oftentimes not possible
when sequencing small genomic fragments
application of whole genome sequencing
improves the bio phylogenetic analysis
by providing a wealth of variant sites
this in turn enables studying biogenetic
association with disease including
genotype phenotype
association studies
in the clinical context
it is of great interest to implement
workflows that include all steps from
sample
to medical grade report
these workflows
need to undergo a thorough validation in
order to ensure meeting defined
standards
yet
due to the fact that molecular assays
such as ngs based assays are in
continuous development a significant
effort needs to go into validation of
clinical workflows that are utilizing
them
so in the realm of bioinformatics data
analysis and
also data management a considerable
level of standardization has been
already achieved
for example by introduction of data
formats
and implementation of tools for primary
data
analysis the tools for clinical data
interpretation and reporting are still
largely at their infancy however it has
to be said that in the last few years a
considerable effort went into their
conceptualization
and development
a way towards standardization of
workflows utilizing molecular essays is
their automation using liquid handling
stations
automation not only enables greater
reproductive reproducibility eliminating
human errors and improving process
control
but also enables higher sample
throughput
so now depending on the application
two
approaches that enable identification of
viral genome sequences could be
implemented
in the first scenario where the aim
would be to identify new sequences of
viruses that for example cause disease
the so-called metagenome approach
could be utilized and sequences of all
species present in analyzed samples
would be sequenced
however
in scenarios where when the genomic
sequence of the virus of interest is
already known
a targeted sequencing of viral genome
can be implemented
clearly as opposed to
meta genome approach targeted sequencing
is a less data intense approach
so generally speaking pcr based or
amplicon-based target approach requires
rather low sample inputs
and it's usually associated with
lower costs
compared to it
enrichment through hybrid capture
allows for dramatically larger pro
panels with more comprehensive profiling
of the target regions
the oligoprobes used for hybrid capture
based target management remain effective
even with within highly mutagenic
regions
allowing targeting of rapidly evolving
rna viruses
additionally this method allows for
near-complete sequence
data
of targeted regions and enables
applications such as variant analysis
for violent evolution
or violence
surveillance
in our effort to contribute a possibly
high number of fully resolved genomes of
sas cov2 to give a database
we have implemented a comprehensive
workflow that integrates automated
library preparation
and target enrichment utilizing the
biomac i7 hybrid workstation from
beckman culture
sequencing on nexic 500 instrument from
illumina
and we utilized our custom data analysis
workflow that utilizes the pipeline
developed by the robert koch institute
in berlin
we have chosen to implement illumina's
rna prep with enrichment in order to
enrich
viral fragments
or targets from total nucleic acid more
specifically reverse transcription of
extracted rna and library preparation
was followed by enrichment with the
illumina respiratory virus oligo panel
the
respiratory virusological panel contains
sequences of about 40 common respiratory
viruses
uh including coronavirus strains and in
particular the sequence of suffocal
virus to increase the library complexity
human control genes are also included in
the panel
while validating our clinical workflow
we simultaneously produced libraries for
48 samples on the biomac i7 hybrid
workstation
that were then sequenced using pair and
75 base pair mid output kit on the next
500 sequencer
now i would like to give a floor to the
automation specialist from beckmann
quilter randy perez who will walk you
through the process of implementing the
illumina's protocol on the biomec i7
thanks tomas and thank everybody for
joining today
my name is randy pearson i'm a senior
application scientist with beckmann
culture life sciences
the illumina rna prep with enrichment
application is a demonstrated method for
the beckmann culture biomec i7
hybrid liquid handling platform
shown here
is the deck layout for the biomec i7 ngs
workstation which is equipped with 26
automated labor positions
seven tip loading positions
an active wash station orbital shaker
both static and shaking and eco peltiers
for active
plate heating and cooling
and an integrated applied biosystems
automated thermocycler
also shown here the bullet points show
some high level highlights of the method
which i will discuss in further detail
the method itself is divided into two
separate workflows
uh cdna synthesis and library prep on
the top and then hybridization and
capture enrichment on the bottom
the method is written to allow users to
select their given start and stop points
and these start and stop points coincide
with luminous publish safe stop points
and are represented by a yellow clock on
the bottom right hand corner
at the start of each workflow a guided
labware setup will assist users with a
graphical interface to show them how to
set up the run
this interface will specify number of
tip boxes needed
required labware
minimum reagent fill volumes and this is
a dynamic interface that'll change
depending on the user-defined run
parameters
the method is scalable
it's capable of running up to 96 samples
for library preparation
and either up to 96 singleplex libraries
or up to 32 threeplex pools
for hybridization and enrichment
users may also vary the amount of input
material from 10 to 100 nanograms of
input rna and can run both high quality
integrated or ssbe samples
the method was written to reduce the
total number of user touch points and
can be run in as few as two manual user
interventions one at the start of cdna
synthesis
and one at the start of hybridization
and enrichment
shown to the right
our timing estimates for each individual
process
the entire workflow for 96 samples
pulled down to 32 3-plex pools
can be performed in approximately 12
hours
the illumina rna prep with enrichment
demonstrated method is designed to run
with biomech method launcher
biomec method launcher is a user
interface that allows users to run
biomec methods outside
of the biomic 5 method editor software
this protects against unintended or un
or accidental changes by multiple users
while preparing to run methods
run parameters are defined using the
methods option selector
this form is a dynamic html driven user
interface
that allows users to select the
parameters they wish to run during the
current method run such as number of
samples the use of the automated
thermocycler
which indexes to be used during the
course of the run
and method start and save stop points
method parameters chosen here
that would create an error state in the
method
such as skipping a step in the workflow
will display an error at the bottom of
this interface
and will not allow a user to proceed
until those errors are addressed
after the user has selected their run
parameters
the guided labware setup will provide a
graphical interface to assist the user
with deck setup including the required
number of tips
consumables and calculated required
reagents
this setup is dynamic and will change
according to the user input parameters
so that unnecessary reagents or labware
will not be shown throughout the course
of this run
i will now pass the mic back to tomas to
discuss his work utilizing the illumina
rna prep with enrichment kit on the
biomex i7 hybrid in his lab
thank you randy
in order to validate our automated
workflow for sask of 2 genome sequencing
we've utilized the synthetic sask of 2
rna controls from twist biosciences
at the input of 10 nanogram and as
little as 10 to the power of 3 of viral
sequence copies we could still cover
more than 94 percent of the coronavirus
genome with the coverage of at least
five reits
a recent publication in the lancet
journal reported standard curves from
papers
providing serial dilution factors and
corresponding ct values in patient
samples
from this picture
it can be learned that the sequence by
us twist sask of two controls containing
10 to the power of three copies would
technically correspond to a ct value of
30 in patient samples
and this is highlighted with the broken
blue line
in the next step we validated our
automated clinical workflow for sars
cof2 genome sequencing utilizing patient
samples from the department of biology
at the university hospital charity
so for the two batches of 48 samples we
took a
eight and a half microliter as input and
utilized whenever possible 20 nanogram
of nucleic acid
for
roughly 25 percent of samples where
cubit quantification implied values
below two and a half nanogram we just
use eight and a half microliter of input
now the insert sizes of the sequence two
batches of 48 clinical samples had mid
sizes in the range between 200 and 250
base per
showing little variation
we have obtained an excellent coverage
of the target region so even at the
coverage of 50 deduplicated reads more
than 98 percent of sarskoff to genome
was covered
so importantly we observed little in and
between the batch variation as it can
can be now seen in this bar plot
the city values from rtpcr of the
analyzed 96 patient samples were in the
range from 19 to 31
when city values of clinical samples are
plotted against the number of reads that
map to sarskkov-2 genome a clear
coloration can be observed
it doesn't really come as a surprise
that sequencing of samples with high ct
values results in lower numbers of reads
mapped to saskof2 genome
similarly a strong correlation can be
observed when ct values of clinical
samples are plotted against the
percentage of reits that uniquely map to
the fast of two genome
at the high ct values of 30
corresponding to very low variable
copies the percentage of reads that can
be attributed to sask of two genome
ranges from 20 percent to 70 percent
implicating presence of contaminating
sequences in the sequence libraries
so in order to facilitate alignments qc
analyzes and tertiary analysis of
generated data we have implemented our
own bioinformatics workflow
we have utilized the already developed
bioinformatics workflow covpi
developed by the robert koch institute
in berlin and added additional
functionality in order to enable
analysis of
sequences enriched with with the
illumina respiratory panel
we named our solution resp viewer pipe
and it can be freely downloaded from the
gitlab at the specified http
address
in the following chart you can see the
data flow implemented by us as an
extension to the analysis workflow of
the cough pipe
on the left in the bright yellow you can
see that we added the whole set of the
pathogens from the illumina respiratory
panel to the taxonomic reference
database
the reference sequences were taken from
ncbi according to the refseq identifiers
as provided by illumina
the main focus of the pipeline is on
copy 19
but if any other pathogen included in
the respiratory panel is detected
as presented at the bottom of the chart
it will be quantitatively evaluated
as highlighted at the bottom in blue
and the
and also highlighted in the
uh final report
which you can see in yellow on the right
additionally we give instructions on how
to evaluate unmapped reads due to
possible additional contaminating
pathogens like bacteria
this part of the workflow is highlighted
in gray at the bottom of the chart
the primary use of the develop pipeline
is to characterize sequences that are
enriched with the specific ngs panel
however
like i already mentioned in the previous
slide the application of our pipeline
allows for annotation of contaminating
sequences
in the highlighted sample on the right
26 percent of all reads could be
attributed to sarskoff two genome
twelve percent of reeds could be
identified as of human origin
and as much as 60
62 of reeds could not be classified
if only human and virus sequences that
are part of the illumina respiratory
disease panel were used
application of our resp vr pipeline
resulted in classification of almost all
of the unclassified sequences into
bacterial strains
strongly suggesting
as a source bacterial species present in
throats of analyzed patients
so in a summary i presented to you an
automated clinical workflow for
whole genome sequencing of viruses that
can be characterized by high sensitivity
of utilized illumina rna prep with
enrichment essay
we could document high levels of data
reproducibility when the essay was
executed on
the biomec i7 hybrid workstation
from beckman culture
last but not least i presented to you a
freely available software solution
developed by us that facilitates the
analysis of data generated with the
respiratory virus or legal panel from
illumina
i would like to thank my colleagues
bioinformatician martin nieger and
technician cornelia for their excellent
contributions
big thanks also to victor corman from
the department of biology for clinical
samples
and last but not least
big thanks to colleagues from illumina
and beckman culture ryan
jonathan randy martin and jan for a
great collaboration
thank you for your attention and i'll be
most happy to take some questions now
thank you tomaz and randy for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
is the automated method available
uh thanks michelle uh yes uh the
automated method is available and has
been demonstrated
an aluminum qualified uh also we have an
application note available as well
if you'd like more information on that
please reach out to your local beckman
coulter sales rep
or your local
application specialists
thank you
next question
what things did you consider when
selecting an automated workstation
um sorry i lost my window there for a
second that's okay
um i i think timothy and i probably both
have some some thoughts on that um
you know from uh from from that my
perspective
um i think one of the big drivers is
going to be
um
your throughput um you know how many
samples are you looking to get through
in a day
um costs for samples
you know if you're talking about doing a
lot of high throughput stuff
um we're we're talking uh
uh
you know but eventually the the amount
of time and cost
concerns can definitely make automation
uh
a better candidate for this
um and then i would say the other thing
too is like your scalability what do you
expect your throughput is gonna be in
the future um
but uh yeah and i think tomas you might
have a couple of other suggestions like
are you online
there we go all right so um
so first of all the size of the user
base and especially with regards to
users from academic community
and then of course the
the number of already implemented ngs
protocols
and what is really important in terms of
on-site essay development in terms of
automation is of course the availability
of local service support
great thank you
next question
can you tell us about your rna
extraction workflow prior to library
prep
sure so so in a nutshell the extraction
workflow uh
is
based on the russia's magna pure 96
instruments
and the this very essay yields both dna
and rna so this is what we use as a as
an input for this essay actually a
mixture of species
thank you
next question
what approaches can we take to minimize
the occurrence of contaminating
sequences in the sequencing data
okay so i'll take this one as well so um
in our case the contaminating sequences
are actually present by nature as they
are derived from nozzle and throat
respiratory areas of patients so
actually it's a feature of these samples
okay
next question
what database did you use when
annotating contaminating sequences
so uh we utilized the ncbi database and
the classification as it was implemented
by uh kraken tool it is actually
utilizing exact alignments of payments
thank you
it looks like we have time for one more
question
there are many bacterial sequences in
the data do they correspond to any
bacterial infections associated with
covet infections
right so um some patients would be
co-infected by pathogenic bacterial
strains and including
streptococcus pneumonia or similar and
that is likely of course to negatively
impact on patients
prognosis
see thank you
thank you tomaz and randy do you have
any final comment for our audience
um well i would i would have uh
a sort of in a line of advertisement so
it's really fun to work with uh
beckman kulta
and i do appreciate this
great
well thank you again to moz and randy
for your time today in your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor beckman coulter life
sciences for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye